pensaron que estaban a salvo de las
bombas encerrados en este edificio la
casa de la cultura de visitantes fue
atacada por las fuerzas rusas este
viernes cuatro civiles que se habían
refugiado allí fueron asesinados el
horror se apodera de esta ciudad cercana
de severodonezk una zona clave para
controlar el donbass objetivo
prioritario de los ataques rusos
visitantes es destruida muchos
habitantes abandonan la ciudad
es emocionante yo crecí aquí hay fotos
de cuando tenía cuatro años bajo estos
árboles
es una pena es difícil hablar
ayer llore
crecí aquí
nos vamos porque la situación se ha
convertido en algo aterrador dejamos
todo y nos vamos porque nadie
sobreviviría a un ataque similar
en la capital de kiev los intensos
combates en el donbass preocupan según
las autoridades cada día entre 100 y 200
soldados ucranianos mueren y este sábado
los habitantes vinieron a rendir
homenaje a uno de sus héroes román ratos
y este joven activista de 24 años muerto
en combate fue una figura del movimiento
maidán de 2014
en esta época tenía 16 años y fue uno de
los primeros estudiantes en protestar en
las calles de kiev y en soñar con otra
ucrania